dragons
that's the first task
the wizarding world can be a dangerous
place so which of the harry potter
actors struggled through the most pain
whether it was because of sets or other
cast members these actors were left
bleeding bruised and battered all in the
name of art so let's see just how much
damage they endured hurry
ow are you right it might be freezing
number one it just hurts so good
poor dan radcliffe struggled through the
most painful first day on set that he
could have imagined that first day we
were trying to get dan's eyes to be
green because that's what they are in
the book sporting green contact lenses
that gave him a wildly painful allergic
reaction this was so brutal that he
couldn't even bear to wear them another
day
we removed the contacts and he's never
had green eyes since which explains why
we never really got those famous lily
potter green eyes you have your mama's
eyes yeah absolutely and unequivocally
no
number two
this queen took him down rupert grint
didn't know what hit him i'll be a
knight
during the giant chess game the moment
ron was struck by the queen wound up
being way more painful than anyone
intended grint got nicked in the face by
a rogue rock and was left bleeding the
evidence of what happened even made the
final cut
don't forget
we're still playing number three like
sun like father after seeing this
deleted scene we can without a doubt see
why draco is the way he is for tom his
on-screen father could be intimidating
working with jason was not always a
treat just immediately turned into the
most unfriendly horrible person and tom
even had the cuts to prove it jason
isaacs came into filming his first scene
with all the malfoy cruelty in check
smacking tom's hand on set not realizing
just how much damage those fangs on the
end of his stick could do tom was left
bleeding and with tears in his eyes but
it's good for the scene number four snow
can do some serious damage the final cut
of prisoner of azkaban even shows us how
felton was feeling about those snowballs
when he visibly flinched before even
getting smacked
who is that a snowball fight can be fun
for one day but going at it over and
over and over again well that snow can
hurt bloody hell harry
that was not funny number five
rule number one don't mess with hermione
such a good moment one of the all-time
greatest moments in the hp series is no
doubt when hermione delivers a knuckle
sandwich for the ages and while they did
it fairly safely on set the prep to do
so wasn't so smooth a film earlier tom
wanted to practice so they could get
comfortable with it but what he didn't
realize is that emma would have no
problem at all delivering a vicious slap
across his cheek quite frankly he's been
asking for it emma has admitted looking
back on it that she had no idea what she
was thinking never again did tom offer
himself to that kind of torture the
sting of that slap stayed with him
that felt good
not good
brilliant
number six the struggle was real harry
did spend a fair amount of time of the
goblet of fire film underwater so the
fact that he wrapped up a whopping 40
hours in the water tank is not
surprising and because of that we can
understand why he also wound up with two
ear infections during the filming
process the pain really never stopped
with this one
number seven it wasn't just the actors
who suffered on this set director mike
newell really liked to get into the
action and wanted to make sure he could
get the best performances out of his
actors when it came time for the weasley
twins to fight newell wanted to see even
more fire instead of the prissy work he
described he was seeing but this
director learned his lesson saying of
course i was a tubby 60 year old gent at
that stage and i really shouldn't have
done it
and why is that well because when he got
into it this director wound up breaking
two of his ribs while demonstrating how
to fight he wasn't feeling like such a
tough guy after that one you know and
you shouldn't break a director's rib
number eight the tri-wizard tournament
was tough from the start while dan wound
up in pretty rough shape afterwards he
did get to perform one of the coolest
stunts he'd ever done a major 40-foot
slide down the roof understandably he
was terrified and his body was feeling
it after the fact dan shared what the
experience was like saying i was on a
wire but i was properly in free fall it
was only there to catch me at the end
number nine not the kind you're thinking
though
matthew lewis struggled through the
early years forced to look like nerdy
neville around all the kids growing up
why is it always me
and then he endured some seriously
painful torture after helena bonham
carter accidentally stabbed him in the
ear with her wand now this left lewis in
agonizing pain nursing a perforated
eardrum he could hide his pain well
since no one actually knew until after
the fact when he confessed that he was
indeed suffering internal bleeding
number 10 good friends know when it's
time to put a friend in their place
hermione was ready to call harry out if
he ever crossed a line and this one well
he paid the price for
yeah that's not what she was wanting to
hear from dan that said her brutal
reaction left the actor with a sore face
afterwards
you're laughing because you hit me so
hard don't you okay
what can we say hermione is a
firecracker you don't want to mess with
number 11. this can't end well and
surprise surprise it didn't as if
radcliffe hadn't faced enough hardships
on these sets filmings left him with a
brutal cut on his lip this wasn't just
any snake he was facing off with the
snake radcliffe was going to tet with
was the stunt coordinator on the film
who was wielding a pole with a boxing
glove stuck on the end of it and in one
take they got a bit too feisty radcliffe
shared that it went up and smacked me in
the mouth and my teeth were really hard
into my gum so i had a fat lip for about
a day number 12 you gotta do what you
gotta do and hermione was ready to get
to work even if harry was hesitant but
she needed that hair to make the
polyjuice potion yikes though watson
definitely did not mean to hurt dan in
the process only to help him but as
we've seen sometimes hermione just knows
what's best i
am still very much in touch with
everyone that i worked with number 13.
emma could also cause herself some pain
growing up on set meant watson could
feel comfortable to experiment and try
pushing herself in ways that one may
normally not be able to and to be fair
she did go a bit too far with this one
acting like you're being tortured
doesn't really sound like an appealing
day on set but it was particularly bad
for watson who kind of lost herself in
it and caused some serious pain to her
psyche the physical aspect was rough too
and all that torture action left her
body feeling really sore and exhausted
by the end but she did give the
performance of a lifetime number 14.
that's not quite the way you want to
leave a set
but unfortunately for dan bruises took
over his body the final film of the
franchise had stunts that dan described
as the greatest physical challenges he'd
faced off with vicious creatures but it
was scaling up chaotically piled
furniture in the room of requirement
while trying to find ravenclaw's diatom
that really threw him the fact that he
spent a full seven hours doing it meant
he was black and blue all over
by the end of the day i was just bruised
and battered
number fifteen it was the battle of a
lifetime
come on tom
let's finish this the way we started
and considering how it turned out well
it was a win for harry but dan paid the
painful price ray fines didn't hold back
and dan could feel it he explained i
wore padding but he missed it a couple
of times so anyone who doesn't like me
can come to the movie and see me getting
beaten up to be fair did we really think
voldemort would go down without a fight
but we did about three or four takes
and it was a really intense moment so
what we can conclude is that being part
of the harry potter franchise was a
serious hazard even if you weren't
acting in it as director mike newell
unfortunately found out which situation
sounds most painful to you